lo sai perché sei qui perché mi sei un
po sui [ __ ] perché tu sei veramente
troppo pacato e mi sta sulle balle
perchè non ti incazzi mai tu sai cos'è
abbiamo vissuto adesso mi devi
raccontati deve sfogare con me se vuoi
ti do qualcosa da bere almeno di 2 10
bella voce da devianza al menu e allora
ti racconto quella più assurda dai
proprio questa è in prima posizione
sono pronto ed è drammatica allora
praticamente giù a bari fecero battiti
live
finita la data salgo su questo van e il
vanni inizia a partire a cannone a
scappare da motorini che ci inseguivano
tipo 40 motorino a roma imbarazzati no
no non è un classico il piano piano
questi motori da 40 dentro mantenendola
30 diventano 20 da 20 diventano 10 da 10
e finalmente arrivano in albergo albergo
chiaramente dall'altra parte della
regione
mi sento più guardo davanti a me e mi
hanno buttato un neonato in macchina
neonato c'è un bambino così dentro il
finestrino possiamo raccontare questa
cosa qui e se mi hanno buttato un
neonato
mi giro c'è
motorino con mamma e papà giustamente
senza casco ha fatto il bambino grazie
per l'aiuto
allora il mio finestrino scende ancora
un pochino gli restituisco il pargolo e
gli sclero addosso per 40 minuti
non ci credo li vedono delle teste di ca
nun c creduto in te lo giuro prima cosa
prima cosa come cazzo ti viene in mente
di buttare un bambino dentro una
macchina in corsa in corsa
cioè non so se ti rendi conto della
situazione in più fa l'ha fatto col
bambino il bambino non gliene fotte va
palesemente un caso perché aveva un
neurone ancora non aveva modo di capire
dove la gente non è normale
no non mi è capitato anche un'altra
volta di una mamma che lancia da una
transenna un bambino c'è questo problema
con il bambino e con i bambini sono di
passepartout dei genitori per arrivare
quindi tutto bene tra se poi questa cosa
genera questa edizione infatti la
separano un pezzo che è solo bestemmia
ma te non capitano tutti non ai bambini
ci sono e ti e ti racconto questa storia
prima proposito di bambini queste per
farti capire la percezione che c'è
online tono da eataly no e dovevamo
andare a pagare incassa poco prima di
arrivare in cassa mi vedono due bambini
piccoli molto piccoli avranno avuto 56
anni che mi vedono tickle to see you
tube
se ti possiamo andare a chiamare i
nostri amici che vi offre una foto non
c'è problema è uno molto carina e molto
vero è molto gentile girano l'angolo e
tornano con 20 25 bambini erano tutta
una classe con la maestra presso e
allora dico senti andiamo un attimo
fuori che così facciamo la fotografia e
facciamo una fotografia scolastica ci
mettiamo tutti in fila ci sono dietro io
alto 50 centimetri più la fotografia ce
l'ha fatta il cuoco di tali perché era
lì che stava fumando una sigaretta a
dire poi del vetro ci fa la foto si è
giustamente il fuoco chiede ma chi è
questo qui e lo ridico lo aiutò buio
toby e file video su internet ma
perfetto e che tipo di video fa non lo
sappiamo
sono nell'album scolastico
non hanno idea di cosa per farti capire
che magari loro girano su youtube e
vedono il mio bel faccione mano
riconosciuto senza però capire
effettivamente magari ti vedono in
tendenza esattamente guardano video ma
non ti seguono perché non capisco
l'esatto non c'è esattamente il tutto
molto bene ho avuto un periodo veramente
drammatico dove mi cito fenomeno sotto
caso momento abbastanza normale così
quello che è capitato e o per peter
praticamente il citofono continuava ad
andare avanti
alle 11 al 23 ancora no così facendo
prendo un cacciavite smonto e ci
crederai ma questa era la propria
immagine per un attimo a gennaio che
sclero per il sito aumento di citavano
mi risponde uccide 5 la situazione
allora ho parlato una volta con sabbia
non ho e mi ha raccontato questa cosa
qui lui era nel periodo in cui parlava i
giovani quindi andava ad amici di maria
mi ha raccontato che la prima volta che
è andato lì la gente non se lo aspettava
e quindi maniera introdotto è scattato
l'applauso e lui è entrato il problema è
che gli spalti dove c'è la gente sono
più alti e più lontani di quel che
sembra dal dal parquet e quando lui è
entrato la gente ha iniziato a urlare
ecco che a quanto pare chiunque anche
una persona come saviano questi problemi
lo mette per la terra che di fatto si è
invece una cosa ricorrente di questi
giorni che vi capita praticamente tutti
i giorni ordini
e ho un pubblico abbastanza vasto che
arriva fino a anche persone non so tipo
sudamericano che parlano la pena
italiano mi conosce una cosa fighissima
solo che è un giorno di queste settimana
scorsa coordina da mangiare mi citò farà
mai fabio fois miranda e mi entra in
casa poi niente in casa con il telefono
fosse una cosa così diffuse genova si
scusa sono in pigiama con quella
maglietta desistere le scusanti
[Musica]